hmm
i think uk guys dress a little bit
better right they're a little bit taller
i think
from well you're from from chicago
anyways i'm from la so um
and they have accents right
a knit
in it
yeah i'd say that's the biggest would
you say
i'd say i think dr like i think
british guys dress a lot better than
americans
for me they they dress similar oh yeah
um
the guys in la
um
i would say it's
there's some that dress
more casual there's definitely a uk
aesthetic i would say
but
it's kind of similar
um it's more
flashy in l.a
um
as far as
dudes there's a
out here there's a different array in la
you get your
a large majority of cookie cutter dudes
the
it's like what's a cookie car dude sorry
it's like i've seen i've seen this type
of guy here i've also seen the same type
of guy here but they're two totally
different people really i feel like i
see the same people in different bodies
all the time no it's like the same
stories but like different people and
the more i do this and the more people i
talk to the more it's like weird you can
read people so much better and you like
know what they're gonna say before it's
like it's a weird phenomenon but i
understand how kevin samuels could like
break people down so quickly it's
because it's like i've talked to you a
million times right that's like when the
girls get like i'm like i've talked to
you like 500 times just in different
women women i would say the
men here
are not more approachable but they
approach more okay than in the states
from
what i've experienced right
like they're more willing to approach
somebody
whether in the states it's like
you gotta look a certain way yeah yeah
ain't gotta be a certain way for them to
even
bat an eye at you yeah yeah
well i feel like here the girls are
uglier
i feel no i'm serious i think like when
you come from america you get a point
a whole point you know
maybe two honestly all right
look i'm not gonna let you do that to
our girls
two points sorry less attractive
wow
do you mean that like
as in enhanced or just
um no i just
when i'm in the us when i walk around i
see more like beautiful women okay like
beautiful we're here it's like i see
girls that are pretty cute and like even
when i see girls here
that are like arguably eights like i'm
like um if i was in like when i was in
l.a i'm like maybe like a six there but
i mean
you know chicago does okay with the
women
but i would i'd say from la you go up
two points from chicago you go up one
right
well okay
i've been tonight oh you said from la i
go up two points no like so if you're a
five in la you're a seven in london
if you're a five in chicago you're a six
in london
okay you do have five times the
population of us that is true i was
going to say that
so
you get all the beautiful people in one
condensed city i can't tell you why
vegas but you also this is like the
biggest city
like one of the biggest cities in the
world
yeah in terms of population diverse it's
so diverse it's very diverse
me too that's what i like that's why i
started the show partially
because i had never been in a place
where
i'd met so many like i could meet
someone from nigeria i could meet
someone from italy like
when also when else am i going to run
into a girl from italy yeah
whose
self value has to be
for everything
and it's not like like in the u.s
everyone's from different states so
that's a little different but
in
here it's like like the cult like if you
go to chicago and you go to l.a like
yeah they'll have different cultures but
they're still american at the end of the
day but here if you're in london and
italy like it's two different worlds i
would say if you go to the coast
i would say if you go to
florida and california you get the
biggest mixture of people like libya in
california i've met people from
the islands from hawaii from samoa so
samoa from honolulu from all the islands
over there i met people from the
philippines
um
where
is her family from uh
cambodia i've met people i've met people
from that side of the world so
but here it's like more of the culture
that
i've wanted to know
and it's just like oh just like to see a
ray of
black people but they're not all from
atlanta or
florida or kentucky or all the populated
like areas they're like oh no i'm from
here my bloodline comes from here and
i'm just like
you know where you're from it must be
nice but it's cool to
to see it and experience and just see
how hard y'all go for where y'all from
i'm like i love it
yeah now the debates get heavy you know
you speak to nigerians and ghanaians
especially those two about jollof and
football and who
and
what makes it different
the rice
we use besmay and they use like bullet
rice oh
fufu or panda damn i ain't a fan of
either
i love me some pounding yeah
so ponder jump is nice
eco soup
okay question have you guys ever had a
girl stalk you
yes
um
i wouldn't no i wouldn't say still
i mean okay
maybe lightly
like i've i've been told of fake pages
following me so like i've been all made
aware
this is this person's fake page
that watches everything you doing
and i've had people come up to me
and basically tell me about my life and
they've like never once dm me never once
commented on a post anything
but they know everything i'm doing just
from like my stories and stuff
then i have to be a stalker yeah i don't
i feel like if you're putting it out
there for people to see it's yeah that's
what i'm saying stocking is like showing
up to your work literally yeah so no
i haven't
you ever been stock dish yeah
yeah yeah um
what happened
so
i was doing uni events
and
one person
would turn up to
the events
every time i was on
like shift
and
it was like how did that person know
but then i was like okay there's a
there's a schedule and then they'd
always message me being like
i'm here oh like i'm i'm here are you
coming
hey oh no
no fool i am coming but
i was like yeah i don't know i'll see
so yeah
i won't go into too much deal but yeah
it was
interesting